>> WORD --
WILL THE DEMS GO BROKE FROM
BEING SO POKE.
IT WILL BE SOMETHING KNOWN AS
WOKE APOCALYPSE.
WOKE UP LIKE THIS?
WHATEVER, GRADE.
>> EVEN THE VOICEOVER GUY
DOESN'T CARE BUT THE STUFF AND
THE DEMOCRATS THEY BE NOT FAR
BEHIND.
NEAR TIME SPEAKS IS WOKE THIS --
BY THE TIME THEY GET LEFT AT TH
TIMES, IT CAN'T BE IGNORED.
THEY'RE JUST NOW REALIZING THAT
STALIN WAS IN A GREAT GUY.
MOST PEOPLE ARE AGAINST
CAMPAIGNS THAT UP AND GENDER
NORMS.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
WHEN PEOPLE ARE FACING A PARTY
THAT SEEMS TO WANT TO DEFUND TH
POLICE AND CLOSE SCHOOLS RATHER
THAN REOPEN THEM, THE LEFT FLAN
IT THE PARTY IS JUST SO EASY FO
REPUBLICANS TO RUN AGAINST.
IT'S REALLY NOT THE IDEAS THAT
ARE BAD, IT'S THE IDEAS WE WILL
HURT POLITICALLY.
SO ARE THE PUSHERS OF WOKE
STARTING TO CHOKE.
CHECK OUT THIS AD THAT ICE FOUN
LAST NIGHT.
>> TIRED OF DATING APPS THAT
DON'T LET YOU SIGNAL ALL YOUR
FRUIT JUICE?
>> HE'S ALWAYS TRYING TO TELL M
WHO I CANNING CANNOT HAVE WITH.
MY BODY, WHY CHOICE.
>> IT'S NOT OKAY, KEEP IT.
INTRODUCING THE DATING APP THAT
LETS YOU CHECK PRIVILEGE AND
PUTS THE AND INTERSECTION OUT IT
.
SHE'S AFFILIATIONS INCLUDING
THEM CREDIT AND COMMUNIST,
ETHNICITY, PERSON OF COLOR, AND
WHITE, MINUS 200 POINTS.
MOVING TO CANADA AND OVER 6,000
GENDERS ADDED HOURLY CONCLUDING
NON-BINARY, NON-TERTIARY, AND
HOW DARE YOU ASSUME CONCERN.
CHECK THE UPDATES BROUGHT THE
FOCUS AND OPINIONS THAT EVEN WE
CAN'T KEEP UP AND THAT IS WHY W
HAVE REPLACE THIS VOICEOVER PUT
THE STRONG POWERFUL WOMAN.
CHANGE MY PROFILE FROM --
YOU DID.
NO, I DIDN'T.
OKAY, WE CHANGED IT FOR YOU AND
WE ARE GETTING RID OF ALL
CHOICES.
>> STOP.
STOP THE COMMERCIAL.
HI, EVERYBODY.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR 6,000 OPTIONS
DIDN'T CONSIDER GENDER THE
CONSTRUCT AND DUE TO THE EFFECT
OF VIOLENCE, WE JUST CANCELED
OUR CELLS.
SHUT DOWN EFFECTIVELY, ALL OF
YOU GO HOME AND STAY WOKE.
GOOD LUCK.
>> DO I STILL GET PAID?
>> VERY GOOD, VERY GOOD.
>> EXCELLENT WORK AS THE BOOM
OPERATOR.
YOU WERE BORN TO PLAY THAT.
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU PAID ME 60
GRAND FOR THAT.
>> YOU WERE WORTH EVERY PENNY.
>> UNLIKE DAVID, YOU ARE SO A
COMEDIAN AND YOU HAVEN'T GONE O
TO SELL.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> WE'VE GOT A LINE COMING OUT
THIS SUMMER.
YOU ARE STILL STICKING WITH THE
PROFESSION YOU CHOSE.
>> YES.
>> HOW IS FOCUSED ON AFFECTING
YOUR YOUR JOB OR YOUR
PERFORMANCE?
>> IT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING YO
HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND.
IT'S STRANGE THAT PEOPLE, UP AS
THE COMEDY SHOWS LOOKING TO GET
OFFENDED, LOOKING TO HAVE A BAD
TIME.
IT IS NOT GOOD.
I THINK WE NEED TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THIS AND I THINK THE
BEST WAY FOR PEOPLE TO DO IT IS
DON'T SEE THE POINT ON LANGUAGE.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENS IS WHEN YO
HEAR SOCIAL JUSTICE ALMOST
EVERYONE THINKS I'M IN FAVOR OF
JUSTICE IN A SOCIAL WAY.
THAN THEY HEAR WHAT IS HAPPENIN
ON THE COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND THE
SAY THIS IS THAT WHAT I SIGNED
UP FOR.
SO DON'T LET PEOPLE TRY AND YOU
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING TO
PUSH THROUGH THIS NONSENSE
BECAUSE IT IS.
THEY'RE TRYING TO CHANGE WORDS
TO MEAN THINGS THAT THE DOPAMIN
ANYMORE.
WE WILL ARE GOING TO BE UP TO
COMMUNICATE.
>> THEY ARE VERY GOOD AT IT.
THE ANTI- BRACES A BASICALLY A
PUNITIVE EFFORT AGAINST WHITES
OF A NO MATTER WHAT.
IT IS CALLED ANTIRACISM, BUT IT
ALLOWS PEOPLE WHO ARE PART OF
THAT MOVEMENT TO BE RACIST
AGAINST A RACIST.
>> BECAUSE THE GOAL IS NOT TO
ELIMINATE RACISM.
THEY ARE GOAL IS TO BE OUTRAGED
ALL THE TIME.
IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
PROFESSORS WHO ARE SAYING, YOU
KNOW, THE WEST KIND OF WHITENESS
, IF YOU HAVE TO FIGHT
WHITENESS.
I DON'T SEE ANY OF THEM GETTING
OUT THERE --
THE AVERAGE BLACK MAN IN AMERIC
INCOME IS ABOUT 24,000 YEAR A
YEAR.
THE AVERAGE IVY LEAGUE GRADUATE
CAN MAKE SIX FIGURES AFTER
GRADUATING.
SO ACCORDING TO THE LAB CHECK,
DON'T GET EVERY BLACK MEN AND I
BELIEVE DEGREE IN THAT HE WILL
MAKE SIX FIGURES.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
AND THEY SHOULD KNOW THIS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT HELPING THE
PEOPLE THERE CLAIMING TO WANT T
HELP.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
HOW SHOULD YOU PUSH BACK AGAINS
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
>> I JUST REFUSE TO WORRY ABOUT
IT TOO MUCH AND I DON'T
APOLOGIZE AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
FEEL THIS WAY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE BRIGHT THE
SITE SO WE ALL ASK HOW WE REALL
FEEL, HE WOULDN'T WORRY ABOUT I
TOO MUCH.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE REPORTED
PRODUCT SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT
IT AND THEY ARE DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE A VOTER WHO IS A
PARENT AND --
MY DAUGHTER IS IN SCHOOL AND A
DELAY SHE STRUGGLING EMOTIONALLY
, I'M WORRIED ABOUT
HER EDUCATION, I'M WORRIED ABOU
HER DEVELOPMENT ON THE ONES I
SAYING, YES, WE SHOULD OPEN THE
SCHOOL AND THE OTHER SIDE SAKE
NOTICE YOU KEEP CALLING START
CHILD SHE AND HER.
IT THOSE THE PRONOUNS THAT THEY
PREFER OR DID YOU NOT ASK
BECAUSE YOU ARE TRANS- PHOBIC.
WHO IS GOING TO SOUND MORE
REASONABLE.
AT A CERTAIN POINT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO GET FRUSTRATED WITH
THIS BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF
THEM ALREADY ARE, THEY JUST
AREN'T SAYING IT.
>> I THINK THIS IS WORKING INTO
A LATHER.
CAN BE USE THAT, GREG?
>> YES, YES, YOU ARE LITERALLY
FOAMING OVER THIS.
>> YOU ARE ON THE CUTTING EDGE,
GREG.
>> THANK YOU.
SAID YOU USED TO PRACTICE COMED
AND NOW YOU ARE SELLING BLADES.
>> IT'S A NATURAL PROGRESSION T
GET CLOSE TO RAZOR BLADES.
>> WHAT ADVICE WOULD YOU GET
DEMOCRATS TO HANDLE CRITICAL
RACE THEORY, WOKISM, ALL THE
STUFF BECAUSE THEY ARE REALIZIN
THAT IT IS GOING DOWN A BAD ROAD
.
>> I'M SYMPATHETIC TO THE STATE
OBJECTIVES OF A LOT OF THESE
THINGS, BUT THE METHODS ARE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE SOMETIMES, A
LITTLE TOO AGGRESSIVE.
WHEN YOU COME OUT AND SET ALL
WHITE PEOPLE ARE BRACES, I
UNDERSTAND ON THE ACADEMIC BUT
THE POINT YOU ARE MAKING OR
WHATEVER.
BUT LIKE IF YOU ARE A WHITE GUY
AND IN YOUR POCKET AT 3:00 A.M.
SHIPPED AT SUNOCO AND YOU'VE GO
A COLLEGE PROFESSOR BEING YOUR
THE REASON PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING
THAT IS A GUY WHO COULD BE
PERSPECTIVE TO YOU, BUT NOW HE
IS LIKE A DON'T WANT TO PAY
ATTENTION.
STRATEGICALLY IF YOU ARE HURTIN
YOURSELF, AND DEMOCRATS, THEY
ARE WALKING ON ORGANICALLY
SOURCED EGGSHELLS.
THE GOT TO BE CAREFUL.
IT'S HARD TO DO THAT STUFF.
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
THERE ISN'T A PLACE TO THIS.
YOU ARE AN ACADEMIC.
YOU'RE IN COLLEGE AND I'M SURE
THAT YOU HAVE FRIENDS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN CRITICAL RACE THEORY
.
SO I DON'T WANT TO PUT YOU ON
THE SPOT, SCALE OF WOKENESS, ON
BEING RANDY QUAID AND TEN BEING
THE SQUAD, WHERE DO YOU FIND
YOURSELF?
>> I AGREE EXACTLY BUT DAVIS --
DAVID.
HE PUT IT PERFECTLY.
>> IT MUST BE.
THAT'S THE BEAUTIFUL THING ABOU
RAZORS, THEY BRING EVERYONE
TOGETHER.
WE ALL NEED THEM.
>> OH, MY GOT IT.
>> YOU KNOW THE THING, WHAT I
FIND INTERESTING ABOUT THIS IS
THERE IS NO HAD ON THIS SERPENT.
IT'S LIKE ITS FIRST THROW ALL
CAMPUSES AND NOW AND ALL OF OUR
HR DEPARTMENTS BUT IT IS A
MOVEMENT AND WHICH YOU CAN'T
ACTUALLY SAY WHO IS IN CHARGE O
WOKENESS BECAUSE IT IS OUT THERE
.
I'M NOT THAT OPTIMISTIC THAT IT
IS GOING TO BE GOING AWAY VERY
SOON.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
WHILE TO BURN ITSELF OUT BECAUS
HE KEEPS CHANGING.
THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN SAY
SOMEONE HAS MADE A DEMAND.
NO ONE IS GOING TO SAY I GUESS
WE ARE DONE.
I GUESS W